police need your help to identify the
person responsible for hitting a 96 year
old Las Vegas woman with their vehicle
leaving her for dead good evening thanks
for staying with us at 6 30 I'm Vanessa
Murphy and I'm Brian Loftus it happened
two weeks ago at Tropicana and Mojave in
broad daylight Ryan mathey shows us how
she's recovering and how police say you
can help bring Justice two weeks later a
96 year old woman is still
important The public's help to identify
the driver as this woman fights for
normal
this is how family remember 96 year old
narumi lick lighter what's going on what
happened and this is her now recovering
from losing all feeling in her body now
it's just the right side where three
fractured ribs an injured shoulder knee
pain and a bump on the head make normal
hard to come by
this is the crosswalk she was struck in
she opted to walk home from grocery she
says across the street from her living
facility instead of taking the provided
shuttle but as she neared the other side
step father
can you remember anything after that and
I was in a house for a bit when I woke
up this is the car Metro Police suspect
hit her a gray or black Ford Crown
Victoria with tinted windows and no
license plate I was worried about my mom
her son Thomas lichlider flying in from
Oregon to be by her side the past two
weeks it's definitely slowed her down
hampered her handicapped her
is right-handed her right hand is right
shoulder or
something
yeah she can't do nothing with her like
that both left wondering if Justice will
ever be served I would tell them to come
forward and just be honest about it and
maybe say you know I didn't see or you
know I was in a hurry or you know
something Metro Police urges anybody
who's seen the vehicle knows anything
about the vehicle to contact Crime
Stoppers reporting near Mojave and
Tropicana Ryan Matthey a news now